[موسيقى]
خمسه احزاب ايرانيه معارضه كرديات تنشط في
المحجر اهمها وابرزها الحزب الديمقراطيه
الكردستانيه الايرانيه المعارض حزب قومي
يقول انه ليس متشددا ولا انفصاليا نحن
اليوم في جبل حلقه
في هذا الجبل على بعد كيلو متر واحد من
الحدود الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
والصر بالك الرساله العراق يتحصن مقاتلون
محاربه الايرانيه لكنها لا تحجب رؤيه
النظام
نحن قريب من الحدود الايرانيه وهي منطقه
تتعرض باستمرار لتحديد الطائرات المسيره
والصواريخ الايرانيه
الايراني
[تصفيق]
هذه صور حصريه لقناه العربيه تظهر القصف
الذي شناه النظام الايراني على مواقع
الحزب في نوفمبر الماضيه
نفذت الجمهوريه الاسلاميه هجمات بطائرات
وصواريخ في محاوله لاستفزازنا لنشر قوات
البشمركه حاول النظام تقويض الانتفاضه
المدنيه عبر جرنا الى صراع عسكري
كان الحزب الديمقراطيه كردستانيه الايراني
حجر اساسي اول دوله كرديه في مهبد
الايرانيه عام
1940 قبل ان تسقط يعود الحزب للمشاركه في
الثوره الايرانيه ضد الشهره لم تنتهي
القصه هنا طويت صفحه الشاه وفتحت صفحه
الخميني
عام
1979 فتوى ضد من سماهم بالمتمردين الاكراد
وكان يقصد حينها الاحزاب الكرديه
الايرانيه المعارضه التي طالب الديمقراطيه
والحكم الذاتي منذ ذلك الحين بدات هذه
الاحزاب صراعا مع السلطه صراع دفع بعضهم
الى مغادره البلاد واقامه معسكرات في
كردستان العراق
للاحزاب الكرديه الايرانيه هنا مكاتب
ومقرات تنشط فيها سياسيا كما لها مخابئ
ومواقع للتدريب على السراحه ان كانت تشدد
على ان المواجهه المسلحه مع النظام مؤجله
للاهلي
طبعا امل ولا اجبر على استخدام السلاح
ولكن اذا اضطرنا الى ذلك فسنستخدم الاسلحه
ليس فقط ضد الحارس الثوري الايراني ولكن
ضد اي شخص يريد سلبي حريتنا
[موسيقى]
الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه